If you plan on doing meetups with more
intellectuals like Timmy Olin and Sam
Harris,
who would be your pick?
MMM,
well I'm going to meet Jonathan Heit.
That'll be good.
I really admire his work.
I think he's a really good guy.
So I'm looking forward to talking to him.
I'd like to talk to Thomas
Soul I or I think it's so,
I think that would be interesting.
MMM.
The rest of it.
I have to think more about that.
I mean,
but those are two that I would
definitely like to talk to you.
I'm going to speak with Jocko Willink.
I think I mentioned that.
So that might be interesting.
MMM.
Will there be a third
talk with Sam Harris?
Maybe this time with Sam as you gay your
guest and you taking your gloves off.
I don't have any plans
for a third talk with Sam.
I wouldn't be opposed to it,
although I think we,
I think we've probably got about as far
as we were going to get in or a second
discussion.
I think the two discussions
together actually worked quite well.
Um,
so I think,
I think,
and this is no,
um,
I'm not saying this in any negative way,
but I think a third discussion might be,
might be beating a dead horse.
Um,
and
like,
I'm not interested in particularly
in putting Sam on the spot and,
and,
you know,
and it's also possible that
he would put me on the spot.
It isn't necessarily the guy
would come out victorious,
so to speak.
I mean,
he's a very sharp guy and there's many,
you know,
compelling arguments to be
made in favor of atheism,
even though I think that overall it's,
it's,
it's a stance that lacks,
I don't think it contends
with its opponent fairly,
because I don't think that the atheist
community in general takes the thought of
serious religious thinkers.
Seriously.
I think they tend to Straw man.